just to linger on this idea of free
speech so there's constant
discussion about free speech in this
modern debate about social media and all
that kind of stuff what what's your take
on it grounding it
not in some kind of shallow discussion
or Free Speech we have today but more in
the context of
uh
Pravda and the suppression of speech in
um
stalinist Russia I hate the term Free
Speech because it's used in many
different contexts some I agree with
entirely some I disgruth at all uh I
don't think everyone has something to
say or something after the conversation
um and you know I have my locals
Community
um and it used to be I think the the
boilerplate language is you know come
support free speech and free discourse
and I changed that because I I don't
like that term
um because people will tell you with
some reason that oh if you block me and
or on Twitter you're avoiding my free
speech it's like okay so I don't I don't
like that term as a whole but one of the
points of the white pill and something I
see enormous parallels with today
if you have one news Outlet or three
news outlets with identical ideology
you're not going to be able to get to
any kind of Truth or any kind of useful
information it's all going to be
pre-filted for you it's like a baby bird
and you're eating the motherboard's
vomit right but
if you have what we have increasing now
with technology if you have a world
where everyone has a camera on their
phone if you have a world where anyone
can put their ideas out there maybe
they're banned from certain Outlets but
they're not literally vanished like they
were in the USSR that is very healthy
that is something I'm enormously
supportive of because back in the day if
you only had the TV Crews with cameras
you can only see what they're capturing
and they could edit it whereas now
we saw this recently during covid right
you had these reporters with masks on
and they're talking but the cameraman
wasn't wearing a mask so you'd have the
people on the street being like look
this they don't believe it you know or
as soon as they would start filming the
guy took the mask off and they'd film
them they go you are lying you don't
believe this you're putting this on for
some purpose whether you're leaving the
ficacy of mass or not that person
clearly does not is only putting on for
show so that's or crimes
it's people you know are anti-police
they say okay the cop said this did he
draw the gun in this guy necessarily so
on and so forth it is so much better
when everyone has access to as much of
the information as possible and can make
that informed decision themselves now
there certainly is
space for informed people to be like no
no no this isn't what it looks like if
you look here if you look there it's
cropped here so on and so forth but
that's still much more useful than just
having that 20 second clip that someone
has decided to edit for you
so like truth has a way of because it's
everything is so interconnected truth no
matter what has what finding his way to
the populace and also there's an if
there's a big asymmetry in terms of
trust
so if I tell you a hundred truths and
One Lie that lie is equal I'm I'm
screwed because once you catch me in
like a you don't have to kill someone
every day to be a murderer right you
only have to do it once so if you catch
me in a Brazen lie you're gonna look at
everything I say after that with an
enormous grain of salt
um so that is another big asymmetry in
favor of truth if someone trusts you you
have to be honest all the time and
you're gonna make mistakes you can own
those mistakes and be like hey this is
why I made the mistake this is why I
said such and such okay but the flip
side of that which has been
disheartening to me is that people on
the conspiracy side conspiracy theory
side of things
I've noticed how easy it is to just call
something a lie yes and then that
becomes viral for some reason there's a
desire for people yeah for anyone who
points out that the emperor is not
wearing a clothes even when the emperor
is fully clothed
so I don't know what that is but that
really seems to mess with this tooth
mechanism so when uh when it becomes
viral to call people a liar whether
they're a liar or not it's like I'm feel
you feel like on unstable ground because
it to me that idea of revealing a lie
that somebody told is a really powerful
mechanism to keep people honest but when
you're like misusing a crying wolf too
much well it seems it seems to break the
system makes me nervous because there's
also like um well just if someone is a
liar that doesn't mean literally
everything they say is a Lie No but what
is a lie and what isn't I I just noticed
that there's money to be made in calling
out something as a lie
it's just
um the conspiracy theories straight up
uh the the the the first thing some
traumatic event happened give an
explanation that's not the mainstream
explanation no matter what whether it's
true or lie there's a lot of virality
and money to be made in that and that
makes me nervous because it doesn't
matter if it's true or not it becomes
anti-establishment ideas are viral
whether they whether they're true or not
sure but I think establishment ideas are
powerful whether they're true or not so
I think on the whole I think you're
right I mean and the whole it's good to
test the power centers but it just makes
me
nervous in our attention economy that
the sexy thing seems to be the
anti-establishment message
and then it feels like that becomes a
drug where you uh everything
anything The Establishment says anything
is that you should say anything in the
mainstream says must be wrong because it
comes from the mainstream I I have that
line that you you're supposed to take
one red pill not the whole bottle yeah I
am certainly one of those people who is
of the idea that they are dishonest far
more open that they're honest
um that said there are people who are of
the belief let's use an extreme example
that Trump is still the shadow president
um and and you know there's going to be
these Q Anon Mass arrests I thought this
was something that like The Daily Beast
made up to make fun of Mega but I was
just on the phone with my buddy last
night and he was like no no if you go to
truth Central they're like all over
there and if you disagree with them they
call you uh controlled opposition or a
grifter or so on and so forth this is
unfortunate or where uh trust Central
Trump's social media Outlet oh truth no
truth yeah but he he [ __ ] he forgot the
name of it himself so he's like you
gotta explain the jokes they've got to
explain the jokes you do like uh like
the the way Twitter puts that context
you gotta you gotta do the joke and then
pause and expl like turn to the camera
and explain and have a left track but
yeah so people know where the jokes are
that's that's how that's real humor yeah
Soviet and then we just clap and
everyone and then everybody clapped
um I think for the last two years
especially vis-a-vis kovid the
overwhelming message was the experts
know what they're talking about and if
you are questioning this you're a vax
denier and you basically should be read
out of polite society and one obvious
counter example to this was social
distancing if social distancing was
efficacious why were there no attempts
ever to bring it back right when you had
different waves and if it wasn't
efficacious why was it so insistent that
we do it all do it at the very beginning
in fact in many places you'll still see
the signs on the floor where it's six
feet apart so there's an incongruity
there and I think it we are forgetting
as a people the intensity with and
understandably to some extent if you
have this worldwide deadly plague like
yeah like it's gonna be go where the
leakiest hole is so you really gotta
kind of get everyone on board but to the
the vehemence with which we're told we
know what we're doing this is the way to
solve it if you don't do it you are
causing Mass death that I think fed in
very heavily to people's enormous sense
of skepticism toward establishment
sources